hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
we are halfway through season X already
what a ride it has been and this week
week five has given us an epic update
and also hints towards a future
including our beloved cabin if you new
around these parts each week we meet up
and go through all the map changes in
fortnight Battle Royale
and we hope to know more about hood
watch we then pieced together a story
theory from all the information on offer
so chill out for the next 10 minutes
smash code a tomorrow if you'd be so
kind and let's dive in it was obvious
what the update was going to bring the
return of Mike's team Maya oh hell no we
couldn't be more wrong as usual the rift
beacon was set up this time in the
desert and something happened we never
thought possible another fortnight
crossover this time with Borderlands 3
known as mayhem we'll get to how it fits
in with the story but let's break down
this new area first how well do you know
bottoms Borderlands is renowned for its
art style this funky effect when you
enter the zone is a form of cell shading
I don't know about you but I adore this
filter which only activates when inside
this rift zone and I am sure you already
figured this out Pandora is the starting
planet in bottle and three over at west
world the Mexican looking town is now a
psycho camp with containers replacing
the buildings and get this the loot
chests here have been changed to match
Borderlands great touch other areas
include the beasts bone seen in the real
game world and shacks and hidden loot
just like in the bottle and series the
famous welcome sign is here too and just
below it is claptrap I'll tell you more
about him later but for now no he's an
arrogant little robot with a massive
mouth did you see the release trailer
for tonight cross mayhem
ever wondered what he sounds like in
Spanish what about French okay okay I'll
stop in Pandora we can pick up cash
which will be for an event and the
challenges associated with that Kevin
the cubes Memorial has been a little
hurt but it's still here in the desert
over by the overhanging pandora rocks
the funny thing about this area is I
actually prefer the way it looks in
Pandora
than when I go outside of it what do you
think by the way I'm a huge bottle and
fan so if you want to know more about
borderlands 3 when that comes out come
back on Friday I have a video tell you
everything you need to know but that's
far too much advertising let's get back
to the map updates
[Music]
remember the chair house in Westworld
last season this season it became a TV
house but in Pandora we have a small nod
to the original chair house borderland
style
[Music]
another great church is over by the
dinosaurs the Triceratops the t-rex and
the
due to how the rift zone has dropped it
has perfectly dissected day oculus this
le a stuff doesn't get old that's all I
love it
ali-a please say more stupid things
oculus but the best Easter egg in this
entire zone has to be the face on the
mountain does it look different to you
it has been updated to look like
handsome Jack one of the best bad guys
in videogame history and yeah he's from
the borderlands series this is a
brilliant I love it I salute you art
creators let's go over to the
overarching story of season X something
in Pandora in the Rift zone is unlike
the others the rift beacon is still here
in tilted mega mall and the rec center
the beacon has vanished whether they
were lost in time or blown up and
destroyed we can't be sure but here in
Pandora it's still here could the
visitor have mastered using the beacon
and this one represents his newfound
knowledge maybe or on the other hand the
rift beacon remaining here could
indicate that this zone is only
temporary and will vanish in the coming
weeks we shall see Oh what if this area
changes again maybe moisty will return
once Pandora leaves I'm speculating too
much so let's move on ok I cannot hold
this in anymore ladies and gents the
erection has grown hot watch his back
baby it's been so long we need a history
lesson back in season 4 when Kevin was
created he rolled over everything in
sight including a small Hut just above
fatal fields it stayed the same for ages
until season 8 when the hut look to be
getting fixed then throughout season 9
the hut began to show us why we love it
so much not one flaw not two not three
four flaws of Awesomeness but then it
all stops we thought it was over but
today things have changed look at the
new and improved hut watch
it has a roof a perfect little roof our
boy is growing up so fast by the way if
watching this little guy grow is your
favorite part of the update please write
hot watch in the comments I'd love to
know if you guys are as into this as I
have actually we could try and guess
what will happen next I think Kevin will
fall from the sky and crush it yet again
I've learnt to understand epic games
they like to play with my emotions
anyway until next week watch forever
here's a funky little update to notice
over in Haunted Hills this statue is new
right I don't remember seeing her
grabbing my attention before I tried to
destroy her but alas it's impossible so
she has a reason to be here what could
this represent likely it's another
weekly challenge but the last time we
saw an indestructible statue in-game it
ended up being attached to a sword which
took down the polar peak monster also is
this a character in the game I feel like
I've seen it before but maybe it's just
a weeping angel from Doctor Who do you
recognize her
who the hell is she I don't know but my
word check out her ankles mmm lovely
okay let's get over to the Depot of
dusty each week we have seen this place
update with new tech put here by the
visitor this is also the spot he made
the rift beacons and this week this is
happening from the look of it he's
either taking the mechs apart to show us
that epic is listening and has heard of
a hatred from players and has finally
nerfed the mechs all this could be
something to do with the storyline the
mechs could be part of the live event
later in the season also as we all know
they have a mark of the visitor upon
them but listen to the sound here at
dusty now could he be adding new
abilities to the mech or what about
using the mechs tech to build something
completely new along with the rift
beacons that beam could be analyzing
things it could be making the beacons
into a military-grade offensive piece of
tech the great thing about all this is
that now we have time travel and we've
seen a hulking great power ranger fight
Rita Repulsa anything is possible the
weirder the better well this week we've
also been given an insight into next
week's update I'll give you a few
seconds to skip
or to this time if you don't want any
spoilers be ready are they gone okay
they've gone let's do this Kevin is back
the floating eyelid returns and it's
even better so is my favorite landing
spot the motel it's on top it's so
beautiful the files that are now in game
are showing that the floating island
will be continuously moving when they
get here just like back in season six
hang on where's Luke the notable when we
need him we need 100 drops on the new
motel okay let's not look forward too
much let's use the knowledge we have
right now to tell another story to bring
us another narrative theory this week
it's about the multiverse basically with
every single rift we use we cause a
break in time making an alternative
version of the world so therefore there
could be 100 versions of the same
character here's how the visitor could
be using that knowledge where the black
bars bring on the terrible music let's
do this
[Music]
season for the first time we meet the
visitor all we know at this early stage
is that he's been contained within a
meteor kept alive by a piece of
technology we call the capsule when he
awakened he knew instantly what to do
and where to go how did he know about
the hidden rocket has he been here
before
after taking the rocket it seemingly
malfunctioned causing rifts to open
around the island but each one of those
rifts was in fact a tear in time the
visitor was using time travel
soon after the enforcers arrived the
time cops and then another one perfectly
identical almost as if they were the
same person the enforcer continued to
track down the visitor until he returned
to the island changing time yet again
reversing the past seven seasons and
freezing time he began to create rift
beacons and set them up around the
island at first we thought they were
failed attempts to get back home but in
fact he was traveling through time to
recruit alternative versions of himself
a visitor stuck in 1885 was found when
he pushed the area back to the Old West
another visitor was discovered fighting
the Horde only one year ago but his next
attempt failed and once again the
rupture in time grabbed the attention of
the enforcer who too was building an
army back in the present day season X as
we know it the visitor is now many
working with a single goal to stop the
intergalactic police force from catching
them but little do they know it's only a
matter of time before the enforcers
arrive will the visitor complete his
work before the war begins time is
running short the meteor will explode
soon annihilating the entire island find
out more next week on how the heck does
that sound to you dude I'm really
getting into this story theory stuff as
usual let me know your thoughts I read
all of your theories and smash your
concepts together to make these little
videos or when I must have thank you to
those who came to the secret stream to
make this theory possible I hope you can
find your name in here somewhere if you
want to come to the next Meetup I don't
say anything here on YouTube please
follow me on Twitter for more details
I'm Adam
so there we have it a great update week
with more mind-blowing changes did I
miss anything
please let me know before I go here's
the legends roll call people that use
coded amaru and send me a video on
Twitter for a shout-out I really
appreciate it
the support makes all this possible
especially the giveaways that we have on
stream ok I'm sure you're sick of my
voice so I'll get out of here and I'll
see you in Pandora I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade it's been a pleasure
[Music]